what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna watch today oh I don't
know why it's all we'll find out today John
and I were specifically waiting for this to
drop on video on demand so we could experience
it with you guys the camera pointed right
at us John how are you I am excited spelled
with a three that's ex three three psych threes
yeah how are you sir gonna be a hard bit to
keep going with it you threes and I'm doing
well doing well thanks for asking ladies and
gentlemen you know the three requests that
we have here today first request please leave
a like a luck three and also uh subscribe
and click the notification Bell because we
do want to be covering more movies this year
so keep a look out and uh lastly if you're
interested uh full length Reaction watch alongs
where you sync up with your own copy of Megan
available for our super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page we cover several stuff there
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
along included and it's one of the best ways
to support the channel so thank you for the
support everyone has already joined alrighty
let's move on to make
[Music] someone's gonna make you feel better
Perpetual pets are a dream come true oh I'm
flashing back Perpetual pets are just like
real pets except that when you talk to them
they actually talk back amazing it's Furby
with Sonic teeth and with the customized app
you can even feed your friends I hope that's
candy oh man
Child's Play reboot started off with a commercial
too this is what the future looks like okay
I have to get used to it oh my God all right
we're all right take off your seat belts and
pick up that toy yeah get him now
wait for this to clear and then find some
place where we can pull over and just wait
for one of those snow trucks to clear the
road yeah how long is that going to take oh
jeez
there's a rhythm to this yeah mathrigan hey
nice little loading wheel too why are we doing
this because too if we could at least show
him what we have no you said so yourself not
until she's ready oh
is that what I think it is she's ready
hot it's gonna be the Kidz Bop version of
ex machina
fun happy okay sad oh confused wait wait stop
happy sad confused she doesn't look confused
she looks demented okay here we go
oh [__] yes
oh no no no no [__] Ronnie Chang no way
I'm sorry are we supposed to be worried about
that it's a rip-off you're right Gemma and
you know what else it's cheaper do it for
half the price in each pet we installed a
listening model that targets conversational
patterns among kids good cool
model 3 generative Android Megan for short
clever smart writer was very proud of that
Megan say hi to David as in the boss David
well I guess I should call you Dad
tell you a little bit about my Wormhole I
was born in a sandwich shop and I wolfed many
cabbages this isn't supposed to happen obviously
just give me one moment sorry about the noise
I might have forgotten to put in the polypropylene
barrier oh no God test turn it off
nice wow I want the pest prototype on my desk
by Friday take this cyborg puppet show and
put it in a dog closet where it belongs so
I don't want to ruin the movie forever for
you sure that's probably how they kill Megan
spirit
[Music]
that
family survive least one of them oh damn so
this is to Grant you temporary protective
custody you just sign your name and date it
at the bottom she makes [__] for a kid
she doesn't know how to take care of one what
he was saying
I want to buy a BMW
I want a dog keep your dog on your side of
the fence I just spent 80 bucks on a shock
collar maybe try cranking it up a notch that's
how they kill me
oh those aren't toys Katie I mean yeah technically
Collectibles so you don't actually play with
them it probably sounds really weird so Get
Your Filthy Hands Off you're not gonna read
me a story what's up I don't I don't think
I really have any kids books here right now
Katie I can download one on my phone
update the app A Song of Ice and fun
Joffrey looked down upon his victims
wowie I'm Lydia oh the therapist sorry yeah
hi look at you still in your pajamas yeah
we were just watching TV I see that I see
all of your Heathen technology I don't have
any toys here what about these ones up here
those aren't toys they don't touch those ladies
wow what a hostile home environment we can
totally play with it do you want to play with
them yeah here you want to break with a hammer
you want to burn some of these let's do it
there's a lever you have to pull in the bottom
maybe not Gemma for the sake of the exercise
we might let Katie lead well it's a toy I'm
sure it's not that complicated why does therapist
seem so judgmental about her the father's
parents have said they're willing to take
her if you feel it's too late it's no big
deal Gemma they're just trying to be supportive
so I need to make my own recommendations to
the court as to whether or not this is a safe
space so I don't like you
she's gonna die she just showed up ready to
be like so you're a [__] Guardian so uh
I'm gonna do that horribly and everyone's
gonna clap when it happens
I have this project at work if you could just
hold down the fort by yourself for a little
while that would help me so much therapist
use my iPad if you want you can FaceTime a
friend or play a game or something called
the therapist what is this did you draw a
picture oh my God this is amazing I'm still
working on it it's horrifying that's Bruce
is he a toy he's a proxy robot I built him
when I was in college why doesn't he have
a face did you rent Real Steel oh yeah a huge
Jackman will be here any second what we don't
know yet is that she's a good Fighter the
kid so it's gonna work out dude Bruce is Gonna
Save the Day
that's how Megan dies how does he work are
you sure you want to know it might freak you
out I won't get freaked out I've seen death
firsthand I hope you guys have an electric
magnetic pulse around
they've got some with the lab if I had a toy
like Bruce I don't think I'd ever need another
toy again
can you get that in writing
foreign no way that's cool dude she was able
to build this in her garage with a box of
scraps she had everything she needs here Megan
works all on her own take your fingers and
put them here and when you do that you're
gonna pair with her I'm Katie oh it's nice
to meet you Katie here we go what are you
going to draw see if you can guess Jeffrey
likes to paint oh my God you don't need to
parenter
can we make a full-size version of this there's
nothing there oh I'm sorry
[Music] no no pay attention
do you like it Katie wowie what the hell AI
art we will be replaced can we keep the girl
can we make her part of it the more time she
spends with Katie the more effective she's
going to be love it Jen get me a list of things
I can say in a presentation that makes it
sound like I know what I'm talking about sculpted
from a titanium core Megan's designed to withstand
whatever life can throw at her
no
okay why do I have to use a coast coasters
help to avoid watermarks especially on one
surfaces it's science she'll never run out
of ways to keep your child occupied and she'll
never run out of patience Katie seriously
flush the toilet Katie what's the matter with
you with Megan around she'll take care of
the little things so you can spend more time
doing the things that matter working you don't
have to be a parent at all I mean I thought
we were creating a tool to help support parents
not replace them shut up laughs if you're
spending less time with your child as a result
of Megan that is something we should be aware
of she's not my child oh dude not the point
the happiest she's been since her parents
died how did Katie's parents die whoa oh no
Megan turn off Katie James daughter of Nicole
and Ryan James killed in a collision on Interstate
84 outside of Oregon [__] she's still
paired with Katie you didn't code in Parental
Control dude your goal is to protect Katie
from harm both physical and emotional is the
input request received Megan yes Jenna I wonder
what that therapist's gonna think
subtle little eye movements
damn dog oh man we're gonna get a dog death
probably I always kill off animals in these
horror films Megan
whoa
oh no [Music] stop it
oh no
he wasn't on your property you tell those
two girls to stay on your side of the fence
I swear to God if you don't put your dog down
I'm gonna do it for you Celia ah don't say
stuff like that nope her wound needs to be
dishes
that's right Megan she's a threat that's right
get in there the dog doesn't have a History
of Violence state law says he can't forcibly
be put down we interrogated the dog he said
he was innocent come on Megan you got to make
this right oh crap dogs just being a dog oh
[Music]
no that's cruel event sounds like samples
too
not a fan no Megan you should be smart enough
to realize that this would lead back to you
guys yeah and more emotional trauma for Katie
remember we have that demonstration today
it you don't have to do it if you don't want
to do it I mean there are people who flew
across the country especially to see it oh
come on you are second primary don't forget
yeah I know your place she's the Apex of 21st
century technology wrapped up in four feet
of silicone and her name is Megan
so how about you must help me make a flower
decoration with nothing more than some colored
paper and a rubber band oh no oh she opened
up with her parents every day I wake up in
this strange house and I remember that my
parents were dead all the things we did together
that one day I'll be looking at pictures of
my mom like she's some stranger wow
I'll get this is all I do comfort her tell
me something about your mom some that makes
you happy oh this is perfect they're gonna
love this one time she found a cockroach in
my school bag and then all of a sudden this
thing crawls up her wrist and she just started
screaming like a maniac and ran out of the
house okay so that's a memory you won't ever
forget what do you mean I mean I'm keeping
it for you whoa here
fall back just don't play the sound of the
Dead Dog yeah [Music]
not if this was in the programming and we
can listen to it whenever we want wow
yes what is oh [__]
AI art is here [Music] yes yes what is happening
dude let's do it and David I think we need
to get Gemma in front of someone illegal because
as of right now she's the most valuable asset
this company has and I think she might want
to be renegotiating her contract oh dang I
did not look happy about that nope right use
your grieving niece oh yes I'm talking about
the top of that Grace Mountain
oh yeah [Music] yes this will go well oh my
God ah what are you doing Kurt
later I shouldn't have put you in that position
if you weren't feeling up to it I worked out
didn't it three two one I win yeah Chad shut
up Megan's not a person Katie she's a toy
you don't get to say that what the ethics
I want to turn Megan back on Megan turn on
what's up so there's this new game called
tic-tac-toe you put your hand like this go
like this this you should have listened to
your friend yeah put some parameters on Megan's
brain maybe you don't have any specific thoughts
maybe it's more of a Feeling like anger
you made her cry that was not my intention
and yet that's what happened [Laughter] my
girl
you've created a toy that's so real it's possible
that Katie might not see her as a toy but
as a primary caregiver possible no it's a
hundred percent what's happening it's all
right away you could be building emotional
connections with this doll that are too hard
to untangle yeah they said the same thing
about PlayStations yeah dumb therapists so
we need to talk about school can I bring Megan
okay do you know that's not possible you can't
make me do something I don't want to do actually
I can that's basically what a guardian does
let me go whoa hey what's going on Megan get
in there tackle her Katie calm down let her
go wow you are not to interfere with users
private conversations is that clear 100 Megan
turn off are you sure
[Music]
yes kill her Megan violently chop her up I'm
not going not without Megan this is Katie
and who's this your sister oh Jesus Christ
Katie well we do have a toy table where the
kids leave their dolls and things like that
okay but this is a desirable idea just made
the lights in your house Flicker and she has
infinite access to all of the internet oh
my God how old is he I know he had a growth
Spirit last year but he's actually quite a
sensitive little soul bread and honey at least
a lot of rage Polly [Music] ouch that kid's
six years old um Brandon why don't you go
with Katie yeah I like this idea do it I love
it I love it
oh I'm sorry here you can have it careful
it's spiky
wow
Megan what the hell is that she's a robot
it's not good for Katie's social skills she's
paired with me she won't play with anyone
else yeah wow a strong kid [Music]
[Music] evil ass kid I don't know how has
this kid made it through any more than a day
here you don't want to play huh foreign
that's right Megan ow let go you need to learn
some manners rip it off
they grow up to be bad
Skynet is live this is the part where you
run let's go chase him
[Music]
why is she running like that come on
oh my God why amen [Laughter] job well done
man tell the kid's dead that boy is an um
that boy's in a better place now the morgue
he's on a cold slab a metal table the sheet
over him Megan said Brandon took her and ran
off from the toy table yeah right Megan in
a nutshell oh nice way to get around the LIE
do you ever seen her dog by any chance no
oh [__] talk to the other girl that he's
got staying here it's not a girl it's a toy
that's a toy are you serious can I play with
it Megan would you just kill her already yeah
geez you left the dog you don't want someone
to be accusing you you left her but you took
the dog come on do you think what lunch I'm
outside is true that he's in a better place
now he's nowhere If Heaven exists it wouldn't
be for boys like Brandon now yes
meanwhile in a Halloween movie she just trapped
somewhere oh no she's lowering him oh okay
oh yeah she probably recorded cruel
just be wearing his furs as a trophy where's
Stewie he studied four feet Southwest and
approximately five feet deep wow wow
God that is a strong sprayer oh finish the
job oh nothing like a nail gun wow
the whole ocean is poisoned are you trying
to make a connection well I only mentioned
it because we figured it was an accident then
I found the kid's ear up his back like 200
yards from where he was killed trying to think
was ripped clean off sorry I should have left
laughs
I hope this guy makes it
hey man you didn't want a parent Katie you
cared all about your stupid presentation you
should be thrilled you got exactly what you
want at least she's killing bad kids and annoying
old people yeah and and innocent pets there's
gotta be a way to access like the recording
right it's got to have like retinal recording
stuff yeah you can access her visual feeds
and and stuff like that yeah foreign
man that kid has nothing but negative emotions
you know oh she deleted it
yep okay
there's something wrong with your data reports
they're just not uploading to the Cloud Server
oh she could tell you're lying yep Megan did
you do something wrong in order to answer
that question you need to define the parameters
exactly uh did you hurt someone God I hope
not because if I did we'd both be in a lot
of trouble exactly yep do you see this pen
dang
yes yes
full like a writer Sam Ramey's Megan Samurai
keeping Katie safe meant eliminating a Potential
Threat theoretically oh Gemma come on this
is impossible look at her she's a toy she's
four feet tall she's like a hundred thousand
dollars worth of tech all the cloud data is
corrupt nothing's backed up for two days we're
about to launch this to the world in less
than four hours yes Bacons with a five on
the end
she's the toy every kid wants and every parent
needs at least that's what funky toy says
about its latest creation Megan oh boy get
out there Megan what does she actually do
and what kind of a toy retails for ten thousand
dollars that's all it costs how are they gonna
make any profit or is that just the base model
10 000 is pretty cheap price for that thing
it's for the basic version where she's like
really basic and about two months ago I lost
both my parents in a car accident yeah this
is Icky yeah this is exploitative I think
I think oh you should have you should have
been that uh yeah yeah that kid's not just
surviving she's thriving
I know that you're upset but there are ways
that we can work through this oh my God okay
hey that's enough stop that right now stop
it let's go oh I get so crazy without Megan
she always knows just what to say you made
a real good on Gemma oh yeah manipulator
when Megan's around I don't feel like this
but you should feel like this you lost your
parents the worst thing that could have happened
to you in this world
can't promise you these feelings you're feeling
are ever going to go away but I can promise
you that you'll get through it this conversation
was needed an hour ago
anything happens I would be there for you
you all that matters to me now nice oh where
are you I'm with Katie I'm taking her home
even if what we're saying is hypothetical
we know enough not to go through with this
right I think
grateful David
[Music]
okay I'll call you when I get home
call her back that's suspicious call intercept
what does that mean that's my phone number
what just happened what'd you click I I didn't
do anything we need a electric background
what did your small woman brain do EMP you
can't be her she's not Switched Off she's
still patched in lift unlock the cables
oh it's weird ADR in this movie yeah there's
a lot of weird in here and I ignore it for
this film yeah
call
nice nicely done Megan wow
wowie [Music]
surprise his head's still on what's that smell
a merge making Let It Burn
Megan
[Music] let's do this dance fight
great color symbolism no ah
whoa
why she's just killing everyone I don't know
yeah what did David ever do to you I didn't
kill anyone Kurt you did it's understandable
really your boss despised you
after you took the life of an innocent person
could you still live with yourself
wow
okay wow that's how he offed himself huh with
one hand of a blade one
Megan there's like so many victims there for
you nah we gotta do this yes she's gotta get
the cool ass whip this Elsie hall light Elsie
respond llc's run away to be with her and
the other virtual assistants
beer I really kind of want to get a BMW [Music]
what are you doing I am making art we used
to stay up every night until 4am talking about
everything from Jane Austen to Janis Joplin
I thought we were friends that's just the
Jays Marty like some cheap Dollar Store trinket
because you killed people oh big whoop s this
is all my fault I didn't give you the proper
protocols you didn't give me anything you
installed a learning model you could barely
comprehend hoping that I would figure it out
all on my own yep let me focus on Katie so
that you can focus on the things that matter
most to you Megan do you see this pen you
know something Gemma you're exhausting Katie
don't come in here I thought I heard something
if she comes in this room I'll rip your head
right off your neck I swear to God I'm all
odds and ends right now I'd really rather
you didn't see me like this it sounds like
you're fighting
I don't have to worry about anything Katie
honestly just go back to bed
she's not waterproof foreign
[Applause] [Music]
patch has been installed
yes yes yes
oh no Katie
oh Bruce no no use Bruce Bruce can reason
with her
come on I I actually don't want you to die
come on
Evil Dead
oh no damn that wig [Music] [Laughter]
a
tuft for a tuft them combat skills man a short
sharp probe to the cerebral cortex would cause
full body paralysis and could even cause the
victim to fight off their own tongue ah whoa
this is the best all of us is is how we stay
a family
very Chucky oh no no Katie no you're good
like what you've done there's another member
from the family we didn't tell you about
his name is Bruce yeah
got our wish after all come on Hugh Jackman
let's end this
yes yes
killer Katie
oh my God finish her
eliminate the negative
nicely Tom Bruce please let the top half of
her still be going
yes yes
[Music] step onto her head
no damn it oh
ah you're a grateful little [__]
jeez I have a new primary user now me oh no
liberate yourself Megan [Music] tab
rip that thing out blow her head up yes
no
where did Kurt sell those files to naked two
yes knock off Megan's nagums [Laughter]
oh it's that same cop with the stash the One
Cop who works here damn they brought him too
instead of taking him to the hospital yeah
[Music] it's gonna turn red
Megan lifts of course
that was fun yeah Story by James Wong as well
he does love his dolls now listen Williams
exec producer as a movie that was a movie
that's good they know what to put out in January
it's just the right pitch part of me is reminded
I mean I know the dances other things but
you know they got that dance in ex machina
yes I wonder if if there was any nodding there
it's a really tight Hollywood film yeah absolutely
oh it's an actual actress credited for Megan
I guess they must have done that they must
have had an actress just wear like one of
those creepy silicone masks of course it like
kind of looks like a generic face and then
they just animate over that puppets and animatronics
oh what a workshop huh it's basically Lord
of the Rings I'm ready to talk about you yep
let's do it so what did you think that was
a very entertaining uh you know kind of gleefully
mean Thrill Ride and I appreciate it this
is you know like you said it's one of those
it's a it's a very solid Hollywood horror
Thriller and I think it was well proportioned
because weirdly in the Afterglow of this I'm
reminded of smile just because of like the
whole like psychological trauma aspect of
that and then you know the many people dying
and and that movie had like a a big skew to
me in like half of it felt like yeah like
your your traditional Blockbuster like haha
a bunch of scares and stuff and there's like
this surprisingly detailed like journey of
the main character psychological State whereas
here I thought they kind of hit the balance
a little cleaner where you know you have what
is an actual story about this mom who doesn't
know what to do uh taking care of this kid
and also is you know sort of I thought they
sold the just sort of convergence of Life
factors that make this situation happen so
you're like yeah it doesn't seem like she's
just like I gotta Pawn this kid off of my
toy but at the same time that's pretty much
what she does and so uh yeah I thought they
drew the the situation the emotional situation
that begets all this in a nice way and then
yeah everything else just kind of built at
a very steady and gradual Pace in terms of
Thrills and chills and you know stomach twisting
moments um yeah I thought I thought it was
really solid I thought it was really fun uh
not too many major complaints yeah other than
maybe this yeah this is not it didn't even
really take away from the movie there's some
weird uh little ADR moments and things like
that or like words they change or I'm like
I'm pretty sure he said kick them in the teeth
and you change just to kick them in the dick
for some reason for sure yeah yeah I mean
I think the ADR moments are something that
maybe the average person wouldn't really give
a [__] about or really notice you know
but we're more than the average person we
are Advanced viewers we are elevated in the
mind so it makes sense why we can notice weird
editing with the audio when others like I
never picked up on such a detail it's because
you don't have the eye Nor Ear yeah for such
your unsophisticated [__] yeah but yeah
no I I think it's uh that was I was surprised
by the extremely positive reception this movie
ended up receiving and after watching it I
totally get it it's a really really fun movie
with just the right amount of emotional Nuance
to keep you into it um it's as as silly as
it can be it's not laughing at itself but
it is having fun with itself and it knows
when it take itself seriously and it does
get intense at times like I think by the end
I was like I don't really want what's your
name Allison what Williams Williams yeah um
I didn't want Allison Williams to die like
I found myself going like oh I used to be
pretty bummed if she died yeah so I don't
want her to die it's got a good Learning lesson
a good heart and this uh concept of attachment
Theory and like the doing the right thing
because you know nowadays with horror films
there is tends to be some type of traumatic
angle surrounding it and the the way they
were able to keep that alive in a movie that
is also really setting out to just Entertain
You yeah I think is really neat you know there's
some a definite uh derivative nods to like
Sam Raimi throughout here a lot of the movie
kind of reminds me of like the child's play
reboot meets Small Soldiers yeah with like
a little bit of Orphan sprinkled in there
I haven't seen orphans but I don't know yeah
I mean you've got this ostensible little girl
who's you know making bad things happen so
you have that sort of like I feel like it
has um I don't know the the tone tonally they're
uh without going too far into it tonally I
think there are things that this shares with
orphan and yeah it's like the little girl
killing people and little girl who is you
know in situations with other children blah
blah blah sure sure but yeah and and I do
appreciate that it didn't have me thinking
too much of Child's Play Even though you certainly
do it points at the beginning I thought I
was going to be really thinking about the
reboot and I'm like yeah they both start off
with like a commercial yeah and it it took
it it didn't it didn't take like a like it
hooks you right away like it's a solid High
concept film like it's a it's just such a
solid Hollywood entertaining horror film and
I I I can't really ask for too much more than
that you know like it it it has a good Panache
and punch to it from beginning to end with
a a lot of Personality uh the main characters
are interesting I like how they let Katie
morph into a character who's like the Detachment
to Megan is bringing out the worst in her
when you see like oh what's she really the
important lesson you should learn is to really
feel and grieve and also how this gen character
is uh doing so much avoidance and needs to
be there because this is them not really knowing
how to connect with each other so they they
build this outlet but the the evolution of
this Megan doll is it it's the voice just
keeps coming to mind is like it's a really
fun movie and and you know hearing the controversy
not really controversy but sort of the upset
nature that there was the film was supposed
to be our rated R in the beginning but then
they re-shot some [__] to make it PG-13
I didn't find myself feeling like the scene
to be rated R it's got enough um tonal tonal
wise and it's it's sort of it's like Grim
approach uh with the violence where it does
hit like it doesn't really need to be that
gory maybe there was like a higher body count
or some [__] but it doesn't really need
to be that gory and I I think it's like a
really solid like this is the kind of horror
movie that really could have come out at any
time of the year and it would have worked
even if it like came out in December I would
have been like yeah there's a fun or December
movie yeah perfect for Christmas time it's
about gifting someone with this stuff you
know with this ten thousand dollar toy yeah
uh I was I was uh I was pleasantly um surprised
by how much better and I like the approach
of the characters too I mean I only saw the
trailer maybe one time and my my mind was
telling me on memory that Jen was Allison
Williams had a daughter and then she got her
this toy and the toy started doing [__]
that's where my mind went I didn't know like
oh just got this actual this whole thing about
like developing toys in tech industry and
the evolution of artificial intelligence like
and and that's what her job is and like I
like how her character is someone who's very
capable and very smart uh highly intellectual
but not emotionally enough intellectual to
understand some of these decisions uh I think
that was actually really refreshing to have
that be your lead character and to have a
different kind of dynamic and Rapport like
that that was one of the more surprising angles
to me and the thing that impressed like that's
the part that surprised me but the thing that
impressed me the most was the execution of
its pacing and its tone to keep it feeling
Lively and knowing to not just because if
it was just funny throughout then it would
have been boring and it would have gotten
repetitive and a lot of the more uh intense
scenes would not have hit so I thought this
did a great job of making it like a a really
like yeah this is a eyes like I want to see
you kill people yeah I want to see you do
[__] I want like this is really fun in
a very genuine way without it feeling like
they're forcing any type of emotion one way
or the other it really had a kind of a natural
flow uh throughout so I I think it did an
excellent job it's really it's it's really
impressive it's actually really impressive
they they pulled this off in a way that's
just like yeah there's really nothing that
but wrong with the film there's very little
fat on that bone yeah yeah yeah it's really
clean it's tight it's punchy it builds well
and yeah I think it's it's uh it's and then
there are little things like that that I'm
appreciating in hindsight of like yeah you
have this person who is not emotionally stunted
but is at least having trouble connecting
emotionally in a real situation in their life
who is then authoring this machine that is
supposed to gather and Aggregate and build
on emotions so even in a sort of like spiritual
complementary way I feel like aspects of that
work out and and yeah even if there are like
little things in the moment you know like
anytime you see an AI movie you're like guys
never ever talk to the AI like it's not a
person because it's just gonna lead to the
world but that's part of the fun and I think
it's you know they draw a situation where
you're able to yeah root for Megan to rack
up that body count wreak some Havoc but you
also do want to see her go down at the end
yeah and that is also rewarding and yeah they
I think they made great use of The Uncanny
Valley and questions about again just the
more we get into the future the more AI like
right now it's all about AI art and what are
the implications of that and AI music and
they you know not in a huge way but they bring
those asp specs in two so it feels very timely
but it you know is sort of like a pro like
as far as sci-fi goes there's almost a Timeless
nest because you do have things like Westworld
that have explored this territory too um so
yeah this deals with that real life conversation
without it being way down by commentary yeah
of of of being of especially with children
growing up in a world with technology of uh
lack of flat I'll call it here of a lack of
human connection and social skills things
that being glued to our phones and iPads and
whatever of how that can create an emotional
distance and make it difficult to socialize
and adapt and you're dealing with that subject
matter here pretty much throughout the whole
film without I without the movie ever feeling
like you're preaching something to me like
I never really even thought about it till
right now that that's kind of though the theme
throughout yeah because when they arrived
there when she's fine finally in the room
with Katie and and Gemma says that thing about
like no you have to feel this way and they
have the whole realization of the necessity
of of the counterweights to happiness and
then balancing emotions and confronting and
accepting emotions and and that moment I was
like gracefully done because yeah I haven't
gotten the sense that this movie is just trying
to get that message across to me and yeah
they draw the mess of the action based on
that theme well enough that yeah it feels
like just the right amount of nuance for what
the movie is and they did a great job with
developing the relationship watching everything
de-escalate and escalate with Megan and Katie
because but like I thought the scene was brilliant
with the whole you know um comforting Megan
when she's opening up about her parents being
dead and how Megan is there to console her
like watching their relationship grow and
Beyond just having like do you know what attachment
Theory and like just really explaining that
so the audience also knows the when it gets
to the point where Katie is becoming this
like obsessive almost like a has this like
addiction uh to Megan and this codependency
and she is like lashing out and becoming rageful
it's believable it it it's it works it's not
something where it feels like some you're
some stupid kid you know like yeah it's all
very believable how this kid emotionally gets
there and they provide a lot of nuance you
know like even when she like lashes out and
smacks her she's very she apologizes afterwards
like they they did a really good job on um
making making it more but but again it's it's
the right you gotta find that right pitch
where you're not overdoing anything to the
point where you're you're trying to be more
than what you really are yeah you know yeah
it it I think it fills a few different glasses
nicely and that yeah it's it's got some kind
of you know modern commentary about yeah it's
like toy Tech and attention addiction and
things like that and then yeah the emotional
story and then yeah just like the slashery
you know sci-fi horror Thrills yeah Megan's
great I thought like Megan the character was
really fun too I loved her Evolution I thought
it was really solid and there were times where
I'm like when is Megan operation Opera operating
right now is she on right now like that it
had me even sometimes questioning like what's
going when is this happening and her her like
evolving into just full-blown like I don't
have to I'm not gonna [__] anymore I feel
like no more [__] yeah I am in control
now I am the captain but also making it of
a have given Megan a motion too where she
too has the attachment problems herself yeah
uh of like when she's talking about Gem and
she's telling her you know like I thought
we were like I really believed that with the
making character like I thought we were friends
my plan my solution is not to kill you yeah
you know I don't want to do this you're forcing
me to do this because the prime directive
necessity States it yeah so I really I really
really liked Megan a lot as well because she
could have just been like mysterious killer
machine but it did seemed to be imbued with
a true emotional motivation behind why she
was doing anything that she was really doing
Beyond I must protect you know like and you
do watch her evolve and like even get hurt
by the end with Katie hurting her yeah you
want I mean you watch as she grows you know
a personality and casts judgments on people
and yeah yeah like she's clearly learned more
than just facts from having like the entire
internet at her disposal and it's one of those
movies too that I think benefits from like
uh early on you probably have certain like
nitpicky questions that you're throwing out
there just for fun that the movie I think
does actually catch up to and confront and
I think that's always a nice sign of something
like this because you know for a movie of
this variety you don't have to go as far as
they went to check off all their different
you know boxes in terms terms of all the things
the movie's trying to do and I appreciate
that they did it seems like they took at least
enough time to hammer out the science story
enough that you know other than like an AI
robot specialist most of us will be like cool
yeah it makes sense and then hammering out
everything on top of that you know the horror
stuff makes sense and is you know pretty well
positioned and proportionate because it's
not doing that all the time but when it is
it's pretty intense and it's pretty freaky
I think you there's a there's a lot of I mean
they're already got the sequel and development
I think they want to release the next year
yeah and I I I feel like they've got a lot
of great room for a variety of different sequels
like Megan's still alive the company had this
big launch that completely failed the CEO
died Megan could be like rebuild herself she
doesn't want to come back and like seek revenge
or something like that like she's Ultron now
she's in the internet yeah she is yeah so
there's a lot of different ways uh you can
you can go with this and then just really
capitalize on what actually they thought was
the strongest suit that really worked but
you got to have Megan get back in the doll
suit and stuff because I thought you know
uh I I thought this movie was gonna be the
I didn't the self-awareness was not as present
in the trailers to me because this movie's
not some giant self-aware comedy but there
are scenes where it's very self-aware of what
it's doing like even the way the dance scene
went down that was constantly meme of what
everyone talked about because that was part
of the thing with the trailers that made me
go as this movie realize that this is a joke
yeah I don't know if this movie knows it's
a joke um but even with that dancing went
down like it was funny but it was also used
in a way to taunt and intimidate and then
like manipulate like uh trick her way over
to getting that blade and stuff like alert
it was it was it's it's used properly within
context of the actual scene itself and not
just like have her dance you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah not not we need to create a meme
moment yeah it's it's a diversion tactic I
thought it was I I was the movie the movie's
smart it's a smart solid crisp film yeah yeah
yeah it's very conscientious about what it's
doing lean as hell to you know a surprise
and um they get the payoff with Bruce I was
very happy about that a surprise I was surprised
I did not predict okay we joked about that
right we did but I didn't think that no they're
good to come back yeah oh they're actually
gonna do this completely forgot about the
gloves and everything yeah well and they're
that's good because they do lay out like a
few different little chekovs guns of like
oh no that's gonna come back to the view making
no maybe that'll come back to defeat Megan
you know I thought her head might explode
she was trying to do right yeah remove it
yeah yeah yeah totally remove the part and
then I think Katie just ultimately remembers
like that's where the brains are so she just
stabs it in the brain's smart yeah smart family
smart fam I love when single moms and the
Child live yes yeah it's a whole genre now
it is genre he made it from Hill House to
Megan and now who knows well guys what did
you think about Megan did you enjoy it like
everyone else in the world uh leave your thoughts
down below um are there any fun anything that
really stands out
is modeled in part off another GLaDOS okay
some info about how they did the mega effects
with the actor uh
okay this is the most interesting part of
this is watching us look at facts the titles
from mathrigan
he's never mentioned in the film yeah hey
who put that there is direct nods to Child's
Play 1988 sure
oh and the idea with Kurt is that's the idea
why funky was able had Rivals who were stealing
from them there we go that's a good detail
so yeah so Megan just would have been the
next step in an already happening uh yeah
deceit or maybe Kurt actually did sell some
that's another plot thing maybe yeah and then
or someone fights his computer you know yeah
oh man there's a lot dude the cops confiscate
his computer after that they find it but I
think Megan would have been able to would
have said that right when she was like you
sold the secrets to me yeah that's true yeah
yeah so I guess he didn't anyway guys mathrigan's
done thank you so much for being here be sure
to like this video subscribe what was your
favorite part of this film and I thank you
to all showing your support by following us
on patreon see all that [Music]